ah what do we do with this this is um it
looks at first likely to be reverse
chain rule away because it's four layers
X square to the power of a half so
you're like all powers I can deal with
that right the reason why we have to
introduce this trig substitution is
because what can they don't tell me
what's the problem what kind of use
reverse chain rule on this what would I
do what's missing because sometimes you
should use reverse chain rule if you've
got into a little similar this there
will be our I'm glad to mention that
there will be restrictions later on we
might as well take note of that I
suppose that you've got a restriction
namely what minus 2 22 right but that's
like cuz you our boundaries are within
that anywhere so no sweat what you would
need if you wanted to use just a normal
reverse chain or this is you would need
an X out the front or some multiple of X
because you need the derivative of the
inside as well as the derivative of the
outside right so if it looks like this
you wouldn't have any trig substitution
okay because you could put a on a minus
2 at the front that would be minus 2x
which is the dube you in the inside okay
but that's another question if this is
the question we've got what do we do now
before you get started substituting
things in you've got to take notice of
the fact that this thing he has three
pieces okay you've got number one your
boundaries or your bounds right then
you've got the function that you're
actually integrating okay and then
you've got the variable that you're
integrating with respect to okay so
three pieces and you've got a substitute
for all three of them okay you can't do
sort of substitute one thing and then
leave the rest ok so we've already got x
equals 2 sine theta I suppose since
we've got x squared right if I square
both sides i get four sides red ok so
that's good that'll take care of the
middle part but I haven't looked at the
bounds or variable okay let's look at
the variable first how am I going to
change is DX if I'm changing everything
hasta theaters I can't have a deal
step right so what should i do together
I should differentiate what I was going
to substitute right so this is where
because X is the the subject here so
we're not used to that but if i
differentiate this I'll be different
shape with respect to feed up okay so
the derivative two-sided is just 2 cos
theta and you can see here this is what
allow us to get rid of the DX okay just
to make it a little more obvious I'll
toss that d theta on the other side okay
so now this is what I'm going to sub in
for this d out ok one more thing you've
got these boundaries ok so a nice easy
way to do it is to build yourself a
little table here okay you've got your
ex boundaries namely 0 and 1 I need to
work out what they convert to for theta
right so if X is equal to 2 sine theta
let's just have a look at 0 ok so 0 is
equal to 2 sine theta so sine theta is
just 0 so theta in this case would be 0
what's the angle yourself either right
so for theta 0 corresponds to 0 now you
do one so this is a separate angle now
when I do one equals two sine theta ok
divide both sides by 2 and you get a
different angle this time namely pilot 6
good and it's also important that you
remember this it has tim politics it
can't be 30 degrees right because we're
dealing with trig and calculus so it
must be in terms of radians so by on six
great ok so function variable boundaries
let's go all right instead of 0 to 1 it
will be 0 to PI six instead of the
square root of 4 minus x squared the
square root of 4 minus 4 sine squared ok
so fast for good instead of DX I'll have
two cos theta detail
okay so here under the square root we
need to work with this a little bit you
can take out that factor of 4 which when
it comes outside the square root that'll
be just too right so that's a 6 very
messy one and then underneath here I've
got one minus sine squared + 1 minus x
squared is cos squared right so i take
the square root you get cos theta so got
to come see you here I've got another 2
cos theta here okay so therefore i'm
integrating 0216 i suppose we can
probably before they're okay cos squared
theta now do you remember this is one of
those become a last lesson what I did or
do we use to reshape cos squared so that
we can integrate cos you can't you cross
way yeah it has to do the double angle
right for crush sign it's going to be
zero one six four times a half 1 plus
cos 2 theta and of course if it was on
sine squared theta here the only
difference would be the same lead all
right do we want most question okay
wrong is there this four times a half
will just be too in some cases it's
easier for us to take that to outside
the integral but here it's actually kind
of handy for us to have the two because
you got 2 plus 2 cos 2 theta and that's
going to be useful for our reverse chain
rule okay sure I can now actually do the
integrating step so two turns into two
sorry not to X 2 no 2 cos 2 theta turns
into side juanita right
from zero pounds now I'm going to be a
bit not even just leave this here
because only one step left I now just
have to evaluate right so when I got to
theta that's pilot 6 times 2 to s 53 and
you got sign of the same angle pilot
three right sign pylon 3 that's sign 60s
so that is root 3 on 2 now when you
evaluate the zero right so minus all of
that this is going to be zero and that's
going to be zero as well so in fact I'm
done that's it ok so again the really
important thing is that you get the
three things that you've got to
substitute all of them okay the easiest
one to miss is the boundaries okay most
people get caps the variable because if
you don't do the variable you've got
this part and then you stick a DX there
and you're like okay clearly something's
gone wrong okay but people forget the
boundaries it's like 00 not a messy
looking six and one that looks okay then
you just substitute in luckily for you
if it's a trig function things start to
look a bit weird because it's not linear
nice angles okay but still people forget
them all right so batteries function
okay okay